This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. All of us know what prejudice looks like. We've seen news stories about swastikas pre-painted on synagogues or news is drawn on classroom walls to terrorize black students. We have heard xenophobic speeches from politicians and watched in horror as ethnic groups around the world have exterminated their enemies. In the late 1990s, Harvard psychologist Mazurine Banaji and her former PhD advisor, Tony Greenwald
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们所有人都知道偏见是什么样子的。我们见过犹太教堂被涂上卐字标志的新闻报道，或者教室墙上画着用来恐吓黑人学生的涂鸦。我们听过政客发表仇外言论，也惊恐地看到世界各地的族群对他们的敌人进行消灭。在20世纪90年代末，哈佛大学心理学家玛扎琳·巴纳吉和她曾经的博士生导师托尼·格林沃尔德
of the University of Washington, developed a test of hidden bias called the implicit association test or IAT. Unlike the very public spectacle of a burning cross on someone's front lawn, the picture of bias painted by this test was rather subtle. By measuring the speed of people's associations, the tests showed that large numbers of Americans found it easier to associate white faces with positive concepts than to associate black faces with positive concepts. Many people were similarly quick to associate men with professional activities and slow to associate women with such activities. Lots and lots of Americans appear to have negative associations about the elderly,
来自华盛顿大学的学者，开发了一种名为隐性联想测验（简称IAT）的隐藏偏见测试。不同于将焚烧的十字架摆在别人前院这种公开的奇观，这个测试所描绘的偏见画面相当微妙。通过测量人们联想的速度，测试表明，大量美国人发现，将白人面孔与积极概念联系起来，要比将黑人面孔与积极概念联系起来容易得多。许多人同样很快将男性与职业活动联系起来，却很慢将女性与此类活动联系起来。许许多多的美国人似乎对老年人持有消极联想，
the overweight, and the disabled. Crucially, large numbers of the people taking the tests didn't think of themselves as being prejudiced, many prided themselves on having egalitarian beliefs. Their test results often came as a shock. The feeling was a feeling of dread. I would say a feeling of having had the rug pulled out from under you. You have to start from scratch to now rebuild a view of yourself
对超重者和残疾人也是如此。至关重要的是，大量参加测试的人并不认为自己有偏见，许多人以拥有平等主义信念而自豪。他们的测试结果往往让他们大受震撼。那种感觉是一种恐惧感。我想说，那是一种感觉就像地毯被人从脚下抽走的感觉。你必须从头开始，重新构建一个关于你自己的看法，
that will forever be a different view of yourself. In part one of the story, which I strongly recommend you listen to before you listen to this episode, we explored the origins of the psychological test. Today on the show, we explore what it means that so many people have subtle biases when it comes to their mental associations. Are these biases benign and just inside people's heads, or do they cause people to act in biased ways?
一个永远不同的自我认知。在故事的第一部分——我强烈建议你在听这期节目之前先去听听那一部分——我们探讨了这一心理测试的起源。今天在节目中，我们将探讨当这么多人对他们的心理联想抱有微妙的偏见时，这究竟意味着什么。这些偏见是良性的、只存在于人们的脑海中，还是会导致人们做出有偏见的行为？
Is there anything we can do to fight our biases? The surprising connection between our biases and our behavior, this week on Hidden Brain. In George Orwell's dystopian novel 1984, there were lots of ways to get in trouble with a totalitarian state. Protesting in the street was a quick way to get seized by the authorities, but you could also get in trouble for subtler things, like reading the wrong book or having the wrong opinions. The eyes and ears of the state were everywhere, and subjects were expected to not just do the right things,
我们有什么办法来对抗我们的偏见吗？偏见与行为之间令人惊奇的联系，本周《隐藏的大脑》。在乔治·欧威尔的反乌托邦小说《1984》中，有许多方法会让你在极权国家陷入麻烦。在街头抗议是很快就会被当局抓走的方式，但你也可能因为更微妙的事情而惹上麻烦，比如读了错误的禁书或持有了错误的观点。国家的眼睛和耳朵无处不在，人们不仅被期望做正确的事，
but to think the right thoughts. After Harvard University put the implicit association test on its website, you can find it at implicit.harvard.edu. Interest in the test surged. Many companies began mandating their employees take the test during diversity training exercises. As we saw in part one of the story, early studies that Mazarin and others conducted suggested a connection between implicit biases and the behavior of individuals taking the test. In one study she conducted with Physician Alexander Greene, Physicians with higher bias scores on the IAT
而且要思考正确的思想。在哈佛大学将隐性联想测验放到其网站上之后，你可以在 implicit.harvard.edu 上找到它。对测试的兴趣激增。许多公司开始在多元化培训活动中强制要求员工参加测试。正如我们在故事第一部分中所看到的，玛扎琳和其他人进行的早期研究表明，隐性偏见与参加测试的个人行为之间存在联系。在她与内科医生亚历山大·格林共同进行的一项研究中，在IAT上获得更高偏见评分的医生
were less likely to prescribe clot-busting treatments to a black patient, relative to a white patient. But soon, other studies started to come out that showed no association between the two. People showing higher levels of bias on the test did not act in biased ways. Critics of the test, including Phil Tatlock at the University of Pennsylvania, started to argue that the test was measuring the equivalent of Orwellian thought crimes instead of judging people on their words and actions. I think the IAT is grounded in a reductionist view of human nature.
与白人患者相比，向黑人患者开具溶栓治疗药物的可能性更小。但不久之后，其他研究开始出现，表明两者之间没有关联。在测试中表现出更高水平偏见的人并没有表现出有偏见的行为。该测试的批评者（包括宾夕法尼亚大学的菲尔·泰特洛克）开始争辩说，该测试衡量的是欧威尔式思想罪的等同物，而不是根据人们的言行来判断他们。我认为IAT植根于对人性的还原论观点。
I conducted this interview with Phil some years ago in 2017, as we featured him on another episode of Hidden Brain. It depicts people somewhat as association driven automaton. I'm not temperamentally all that comfortable with that format reductionism, but I wouldn't reject the test on that basis. And I don't reject the test. It's a little bit different. I mean, it's a test that is enormously intuitively appealing. I mean, I've never seen a psychological test take off the way the IAT has and the way it's gripped the popular imagination, the way it has, because it just seems on its surface
我几年前在2017年对菲尔进行了这次采访，当时我们在《隐藏的大脑》的另一期节目中介绍了他的研究。它把人们在某种程度上描绘成由联想驱动的自动机。从气质上讲，我对这种形式的还原论并不是很习惯，但我不会在此基础上拒绝这个测试。而且我也没有拒绝这个测试。这有点不同。我的意思是，这是一个在直观上极具吸引力的测试。我的意思是，我从未见过哪个心理测试像IAT那样迅速走红，并以那种方式抓住了公众的想象力，因为它表面上看起来
to be measuring something like prejudice. You've got the differential reaction times, right, between the black and white stimuli, say, and it just seems to be a bullseye. And anybody who denies it is engaging as some kind of scholastic quibbling. But there is the question of whether or not people who score as prejudiced on the IET
就像是在衡量诸如偏见之类的事情。比如，你有黑色和白色刺激物之间的差异反应时间，这似乎正中靶心。任何否认这一点的人都在进行某种经院式的诡辩。但问题是，在IAT中被评定为有偏见的人，
actually act in the discriminatory ways toward other human beings in real world situations. And if they don't, if there is very close to zero relationship between those two things, what exactly is the IET measuring? Metaanalyses studies tracking a body of research not just an individual experiment are one way to tell if something is a fad or a fact. If you have a number of studies linking a medication with positive patient outcomes, for example, you become more certain that the medication actually works.
在现实世界的境况中，是否真的会对其他人做出歧视性的行为。如果他们不这样做，如果这两者之间的关系接近于零，那么IAT究竟在衡量什么？荟萃分析研究追踪了一系列研究（而不仅仅是个别实验），是判断某事是一时风尚还是客观事实的一种方法。例如，如果你有多项研究将某种药物与积极的患者疗效联系起来，你就会更加确信该药物确实有效。
META analysis of the IAT test data found mixed results. Some studies showed a connection between implicit bias and real-world discrimination, but plenty of others did not. For many critics of the test, this was vindication that the test was useless and that the hype over the test was unfounded. Challenges to the usefulness of Ma Zareen's research were published in peer-reviewed academic journals. Soon, Ma Zareen and her colleagues decided to launch a comprehensive meta-analysis of their own. I asked her if she found there was a correlation between implicit biases
对IAT测试数据的荟萃分析发现了复杂的结​​果。一些研究表明隐性偏见与现实世界的歧视之间存在联系，但也有大量研究没有发现这种联系。对于该测试的许多批评者来说，这证明了该测试是无用的，并且对该测试的炒作是毫无根据的。对玛扎琳研究实用性的性质的质疑发表在同行评审的学术期刊上。不久，玛扎琳和她的同事决定发起他们自己的全面荟萃分析。我问她是否发现隐性偏见与
and real world behavior. The strength of the correlation is small. When scientists measure whether two things are correlated to each other, they use a scale from zero to one. Toler people tend to be heavier people, so height and weight are correlated. It doesn't mean every tall person is going to weigh more than every short person. All it says is that there is a relationship between the two. As height goes up, you're likely to weigh more. But there are lots of things that are not correlated. Taller people, for example, are not better at math. The closer a correlation between two things is to zero, the less likely the two things
现实世界行为之间存在相关性。相关性的强度很小。当科学家测量两件事物是否相关时，他们使用从零到一的量表。高个子的人往往也较重，因此身高和体重是相关的。这并不意味着每个高个子都会比每个矮个子重。它所表达的只是两者之间存在一种关系。随着身高的增加，你更有可能更重。但也有许多事情是不相关的。例如，更高的人并不更擅长数学。两件事物之间的相关性越接近零，这两件事物越不可能相关。
are correlated. And when it came to Maserine's analysis of the IAT? We published a paper that probably places the correlation at the smallest it has ever been reported to be, around 0.1. And that's because we decided to include every single study no matter how poorly it was conducted. So we decided we will not throw any study out. There are studies in there that really don't belong. Somebody did a study looking at where the race bias would predict their degree of smoking.
而当谈到玛扎琳对IAT的分析时呢？我们发表了一篇论文，它所指出的相关性可能是迄今为止被报道过的最小的，大约是0.1。这是因为我们决定将每一项研究都包括在内，无论其进行得多么糟糕。所以我们决定不排除任何研究。里面确实有一些不属于那里的研究。有人做了一项研究，看看种族偏见是否能预测他们的吸烟程度。
There should be no correlation, but that study is in there and it counts as a lack of correlation. So we have gone, you know, overboard in making sure that no matter what the study we will include it, and so we show that even when you do that, the correlation is about 0.1, within that set, if you begin to use five criteria for what is a good study, that any scientist would agree, you know, The correlation jumps up to three times that size. I first read about Maasareen's work and the IAT around 20 years ago. It's fair to say I initially thought it would show that individuals with implicit biases
本不应该有相关性，但那项研究就在里面，并且它被算作缺乏相关性。所以我们可以说是做过了头，确保无论什么研究我们都会将之纳入，因此我们表明，即使你这样做，相关性大约也是0.1；在该组中，如果你开始使用五个关于什么是好研究的标准（任何科学家都会赞同的标准），相关性就会飙升至三倍大小。我大约在20年前首次读到玛扎琳的工作和IAT。公平地说，我最初以为它会表明具有隐性偏见的个人
always act in biased ways. I wrote about the test in my 2010 book The Hidden Brain. As mixed data started to emerge in the last decade, I found myself having to question my beliefs. There was no doubt that large numbers of people around the world showed fast or slow associations on the tests. And the results of the tests generally matched our intuitions about the nature of prejudice. Across many countries, people more swiftly associated men, rather than women, with concepts related to science or leadership. Groups that were in the majority often had negative biases about minorities. The data coming in were voluminous. This wasn't about a couple of studies and a few dozen subjects.
总是以有偏见的方式行事。我在2010年出版的书《隐藏的大脑》中写到了这个测试。随着过去十年混合数据的出现，我发现自己不得不质疑自己的信念。毫无疑问，世界各地的大量人群在测试中表现出快速或缓慢的联想。而且测试的结果通常符合我们对偏见本质的直觉。在许多国家，人们更快地将男性而不是女性与科学或领导力相关的概念联系起来。占多数的群体往往对少数群体抱有消极偏见。涌入的数据非常庞大。这不是关于几项研究和几十个受试者的事情。
There were hundreds of studies and millions of test takers. But if people's test results were only weekly correlated with real world behavior, what did these results mean? Did it really make sense for companies around the world to mandate their employees take these tests? Some were even using test results to figure out who should be involved with HR and hiring, or rising to leadership positions. As critics and supporters use the studies as ammunition for their pet beliefs, Maserine and her colleagues kept doing research.
有数百项研究和数百万测试者。但是，如果人们的测试结果与现实世界的行为只有微弱的相关性，这些结果意味着什么？世界各地的公司强制要求员工参加这些测试真的有意义吗？有些人甚至使用测试结果来确定谁应该参与人力资源和招聘工作，或者晋升到领导岗位。正当批评者和支持者将这些研究作为他们个人信念的弹药时，玛扎琳和她的同事们仍在继续研究。
The volume of data rolling in meant that they could do something that most social scientists working in other areas could only dream about. They could start to analyze relationships between test results and real-world behavior, not at the level of individuals, or even at the level of companies, but at the level of cities, regions, and nations. In 2009, they reported preliminary results on an unusual finding. We had data from a few countries, not as many as we have today, so we are in the process of replicating that to see if with so much more data, because we did this a long time ago, in which we knew that there was a standardized test that was taken across countries in eighth grade and we could get the data on the gender difference in performance on that mathematics test taken in eighth grade across many countries.
滚滚而来的海量数据意味着他们可以做一些在其他领域工作的绝大多数社会科学家只能梦想的事情。他们可以开始分析测试结果与现实世界行为之间的关系，不是在个人层面，甚至不是在公司层面，而是在城市、地区和国家层面。2009年，他们报告了一个不同寻常发现的初步结果。我们当时掌握了来自少数国家的数据，不如今天这么多，所以我们正在进行复制，看看在拥有如此之多的数据（因为我们很久以前就做了这个）的情况下是否如此。我们知道有一个标准化测试是在八年级时跨国进行的，我们可以获得许多国家八年级学生数学测试表现中性别差异的数据。
And so for each country, you compute the gender difference. What is the gender difference in country A? It could be big. If boys score a lot higher than the girls, that's a big difference. There might be countries where boys and girls score about the same. So you have a lot of countries with a bunch of variation in gender. And what you're looking to see is whether the countries that show the largest difference in math performance between girls and boys are also the countries whose people are carrying in their heads
因此，对于每个国家，你都可以计算出性别差异。A国的性别差异是多少？它可能很大。如果男生的分数比女生高得多，那就是一个很大的差异。有些国家的男生和女生分数可能差不多。所以你有很多国家，在性别上存在一堆变异。而你要寻找的是，那些在女孩和男孩之间表现出最大数学成绩差异的国家，是否也是那些人们在头脑中存有
a stronger association of boys with math rather than girls with math. And we reported that there is a robust positive correlation. Countries with higher gender bias are also the countries where the girls are underperforming compared to boys to a greater extent. I want to take a moment to sit with this finding. At the time she did this study, Mazarin didn't think much of it. But what she was finding was that when you give people an implicit association test, measuring how quickly the associate concepts in mathematics with men, rather than with women, they were
更强烈地将男孩与数学联系起来，而不是女孩与数学联系起来的国家。我们报告说，存在稳健的正相关关系。性别偏见越高的国家，女孩在很大程度上落后于男孩的程度也越高。我想花一点时间来体会这个发现。在她进行这项研究的时候，玛扎琳并没有把这当回事。但她发现的是，当你给人们做一个隐性联想测验，衡量他们将数学概念与男性而不是女性联系起来的速度有多快时，
regional differences, national differences in test scores. When you averaged implicit bias scores across entire countries, people in some countries were faster than others when it came to associating men with math and slower in associating women with math. Now if you turn to how eighth grade students were doing in the standardized math test, girls in countries with high implicit bias were doing worse than girls in countries with low implicit bias.
测试分数存在地区差异和国家差异。当你对整个国家的隐性偏见分数进行平均时，在将男性与数学联系起来时，某些国家的人比其他人更快，而在将女性与数学联系起来时则较慢。现在，如果你转向八年级学生在标准数学测试中的表现，隐性偏见程度高的国家的女孩表现得比隐性偏见程度低的国家的女孩更差。
The interesting thing is that if you look not at a nation but at an individual student or an individual school, you might see little to no correlation between implicit bias test results and student performance on the standardized mathematics test. Or you might find it in one school, but not in the next. It's only when you step back and looked at the big picture that you saw a robust correlation. It was like one of those pixelated images, or a painting that uses the style known as pointillism. Up close, you just see a lot of dots. It's only when you step back, you realize, oh, there's a picture here.
有趣的是，如果你看的不是一个国家，而是一个单独的学生或一所单独的学校，你可能会发现隐性联想测验结果与学生在标准化数学测试中的表现之间几乎没有相关性。或者你可能在一所学校发现它，但在下一所学校却没有。只有当你退后一步，审视宏观画面时，你才会看到稳健的相关性。这就像那些像素化的图像之一，或是使用点彩派风格的画作。近看，你只看到许多点。只有当你退后一步，你才会意识到，哦，这里有一幅画。
That paper, while I always thought that was an interesting result, I think I wasn't smart enough to realize that the reason we were getting a fairly substantial correlation is because we were wiping out lots of individual-level error. We were collapsing across many different people to come up with a much more stable score of what is going on in the larger system, in the larger environment in which people are sitting. And when you take the average of that, the average of a whole bunch of people, you're likely to pick up the actual or true correlation in
虽然我一直认为那篇论文是一个有趣的结果，但我想我当时还不够聪明，没有意识到我们之所以能得到相当大的相关性，是因为我们消除了大量的个人层面误差。我们跨越了许多不同的人进行归纳，从而得出了一个更加稳定的分数，反映了人们所处的大系统、大环境中正在发生的事情。当你取其平均值、一大群人的平均值时，你更有可能以
a much better way. When someone gives you a test, you feel the test is saying something about you. That is true, but also not completely true when it comes to the implicit association test. Yes, at one level, the tests are telling you about something that is inside your head. But the tests might be telling you something much more important about the culture in which you are living. When we come back, what happens when we look at the implicit association test not at the level of individuals, but at the level of cities, counties and nations? You're listening to Hidden Brain.
更好的方式捕捉到实际或真实的相关性。当某人给你做一个测试时，你会觉得这个测试是在说关于你的某些事情。这是真的，但对于隐性联想测验来说，这也不是完全正确。是的，在某种程度上，测试告诉你的是你脑海中的某些东西。但测试可能在告诉你关于你所生活的文化的更重要的事情。当我们回来时，当我们看待隐性联想测验时，不是从个人的层面，而是从城市、县和国家的层面来看，会发生什么？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. The implicit association test became very popular after psychologist Mazurine Banaji and her colleagues placed the test on the Harvard website. Millions of people took the test, hoping it would give them a glimpse into their own minds. I took the race win and to be honest with you I was really surprised at how insightful it was. Does that score mean that I do not like European Americans? No. It's my subconscious aware of the condition that African Americans are in in this country at this particular point.
我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。隐性联想测验在心理学家玛扎琳·巴纳吉和她的同事将该测试放到哈佛网站上后变得非常受欢迎。数百万人参加了测试，希望它能让他们深入了解自己的内心。我参加了种族测试，说实话，我真的很惊讶它是多么富有洞察力。这个分数是否意味着我不喜欢欧罗巴裔美国人？不是的。这是我的潜意识意识到非裔美国人在这个特定时期在这个国家所处的状况。
Is it because I can't come just to say that I'm bad? And is it just in our nature that there has to be an us in them? And them is going to be the bad guy. But as researchers evaluated whether test results revealed real world behavior, they found mixed results. Sometimes people who showed high bias on the implicit association test acted in ways that were biased, but at other times, they didn't. When you looked at all the studies together, the correlation between individual implicit
难道是因为我不能只说我很坏吗？难道我们的天性中就注定必须有“我们”和“他们”吗？而“他们”注定要成为坏人。但随着研究人员评估测试结果是否揭示了现实世界的行为，他们发现了复杂的结​​果。有时，在隐性联想测验中表现出高度偏见的人以有偏见的方式行事，但有时却没有。当你把所有的研究放在一起看时，个人隐性
bias test results and individual real world outcomes was small. But the torrent of data from IAT test takers around the United States and around the world meant researchers could now start to analyze not just links between test results and individual behavior, but the correlations between average scores in an area and real world outcomes. Early on, Maserine and her colleagues discovered a curious result. The performance of boys and girls in an eighth-grade standardized math test appeared to be linked to average implicit bias scores in those nations.
偏见测试结果与个人现实世界结果之间的相关性很小。但是，来自美国各地和世界各地的IAT测试者的海量数据意味着，研究人员现在不仅可以开始分析测试结果与个人行为之间的联系，还可以分析某个地区的平均得分与现实世界结果之间的相关性。早期，玛扎琳和她的同事发现了一个奇怪的结果。男孩和女孩在八年级标准数学测试中的表现似乎与这些国家的平均隐性偏见得分有关。
Countries where people were quicker to associate men with signs showed a wider gap in test scores. Girls did worse on the standardized test. In time, other research along these lines started to emerge. So, Raj Chetty, for example, my colleague in economics, is interested in not only why upward mobility is so slow these days compared to what it was, why the American dream has vanished, but he's also interested in for whom is the American dream more likely and less likely. And so he took our data and said, well, we can look county by county at IAT. So now forget the individual. Instead, identify the county and take the average IAT of all the people in that county and give it just one score. So you collapse across all the people in the county and you come up with one I counties, and you look to see if that predicts upward
人们更快地将男性与科学联系起来的国家，在测试分数上表现出更大的差距。女孩在标准化测试中表现更差。随着时间推移，沿着这些思路的其他研究开始出现。所以，例如，我的经济学同事拉杰·切蒂不仅对为什么如今的向上流动性比过去慢得多、为什么美国梦已经消失感兴趣，他还对美国梦更有可能和更不太可能降临在谁身上感兴趣。因此他采用了我们的数据并表示，好吧，我们可以按县来查看IAT。所以现在抛开个人。相反，确定该县并取该县所有人平均的IAT，并给它一个单一的分数。因此，你将该县所有人汇集起来，得出一个I县分数，并看看这能否预测黑人美国人的向上
mobility for black Americans. In other words, he shows that the higher the race bias, average race bias in a county, the harder it is for black people in that county to be upwardly mobile. This is just one example. Now that we've understood what the correlation is, I can just rattle off for you. You know, now I think we're up to about 17 independent studies that have been published, that show that higher race bias in a county will predict greater lethal use of force by police against black Americans. The most recent study shows greater militarization of police departments in those counties, greater threats to maternal health and infant health in the
流动性。换句话说，他表明，一个县的种族偏见越高、平均种族偏见越高，该县的黑人就越难实现阶层上升。这只是一个例子。现在我们已经了解了相关性是什么，我可以为你脱口而出。你知道，现在我认为我们已经有了大约 17 项已发表的独立研究，它们表明一个县更高的种族偏见将预测警察对黑人美国人更严重地使用致命武力。最新研究显示，在偏见更大的县，警察部门的军事化程度更高，那些偏见更大的县
counties that have greater bias, school disciplining differences between white and black kids that are greater in counties that have greater race bias, traffic stops, tickets, et cetera. And these 17 studies that I'm just mentioning that look at average IAT scores by county or by state or by metropolitan region or by country, they're all averages by region. They are just predicting up and down the spectrum in a way in which I would never have predicted,
孕产妇健康和婴儿健康受到的威胁更大，白人儿童和黑人儿童之间的学校纪律处分差异在种族偏见更大的县也更大，交通拦截、罚单等等。我刚才提到的这 17 项研究着眼于按县、按州、按大都市区或按国家划分的平均 IAT 分数，它们全都是按地区划分的平均值。它们以我永远无法预测的方式预测了光谱的高低，
but it's really exciting to see because these dependent variables are not simple little things. It's not even how well you do on a math test. This is about whether you live or die. This is about whether you will get disciplined in school and get kicked out. This is about whether you will live as a baby. Can you talk a little bit about why it is we would see a stronger correlation at this aggregate level? So in other words, if you're analyzing my brain and saying, here's your implicit bias and then you're evaluating me to see, do I hire a black person or a white person?
但看到这一结果真的很令人兴奋，因为这些因变量并不是微不足道的小事。这甚至不仅关于你在数学测试中表现得有多好。这关乎你是生是死。这关乎你是否会在学校受到纪律处分并被开除。这关乎你作为一个婴儿能否活下来。你能多谈谈为什么我们会在这个聚合层面上看到更强的相关性吗？换句话说，如果你在分析我的大脑并说，这是你的隐性偏见，然后你评估我，看我是否会雇佣一个黑人或一个白人？
Do I hire a man or a woman? Why is it that we would see a lower correlation at me and an individual? But when you step out and look at the aggregate, you have a higher correlation. How would that be the case? That's the power of aggregation. Any individual score is going to vary based on lots of things jittering around in that moment.
我是否会雇佣一个男人或一个女人？为什么我们在“我”这个个体身上会看到较低的相关性？但当你退一步看总量时，相关性却更高了？这怎么可能呢？这就是聚合的力量。任何个人的得分都会根据那一刻周围乱七八糟的许多事情而发生变化。
And more importantly, whether you behave in a way that is biased or less biased is going to be multiply determined by little things in the local environment. For example, my score on race bias may be quite high. I may be quite anti-black, but it may be that in the moment in which you're testing my behavior, a smiling person appeared in front of me who wiped out my bias and I responded positively to that person. Little things like that in the environment can make the behavior move around and not allow
更重要的是，你的行为是有偏见的还是较少偏见的，将由当地环境中的微小事物共同决定。例如，我对种族偏见的得分可能相当高。我可能相当反黑人，但可能正是在你测试我行为的那一瞬间，一个微笑的人出现在我面前，抹去了我的偏见，我对那个人做出了积极的反应。环境中诸如此类的小事可以使行为发生波动，而不允许
the particular measure in which you're interested in to show itself. So as soon as you aggregate it for every person like me, somebody else's similar behavior will counter it. And so all you are doing the best way to understand it is that when we aggregate, we are removing individual level noise in the data. One analogy to this idea comes from the realm of polling. In the United States, lots of polling is done by groups that have either a conservative or a liberal bias. Unsurprisingly, polls that lean conservative are likely to predict conservative victories. Liberal polls are likely to predict victories for Democrats.
你感兴趣的特定测量结果显现出来。因此，一旦你为像我这样的每个人进行聚合，另一个人的类似行为就会抵消它。所以你所做的——理解这一点的最好方法是——当我们进行聚合时，我们消除了数据中的个体层面噪音。这个想法的一个类比来自民意调查领域。在美国，许多民意调查都是由带有保守派或自由派偏见的群体进行的。毫无疑问，倾向保守派的民意调查更有可能预测保守派的胜利。自由派的民意调查更有可能预测民主党的胜利。
But something interesting happens when you average out the polls. The poll that leans too far right gets balanced out by the poll that leans left. When you average polls, you are likely to get answers that are much more accurate than individual polls. The same thing happens if you ask people to make estimates of something, say the size of the US economy. Low estimates and high estimates cancel each other out when you average the answers, leaving you with a better approximation of the correct answer. This phenomenon is sometimes known as the wisdom of the crowd, meaning the average answer across a group of people is often more accurate than
但当你对民意调查进行平均时，有趣的事情发生了。过于偏右的民意调查会被倾向左翼的民意调查所平衡。当你对民意调查进行平均时，你很可能会得到比单个民意调查准确得多的答案。如果你让人们对某事进行估计，比如说美国经济的规模，也会发生同样的事情。当你对答案进行平均时，低估和高估会相互抵消，从而为你留下对正确答案更好的近似。这种现象有时被称为“群体智慧”，意味着跨人群的平均答案往往比
individual answers. Now there are two views on this. The two views are my view is that as we remove noise we will see higher and higher levels of correlation. In other words as the tests get, as studies are conducted more carefully, Ma Zerina saying she expects the correlations to get better at the individual level, not just at the level of nations. But she also cites a second possibility, that the IAT is really capturing a reflection in people's minds of something that is in the larger culture. Somebody I admire greatly and agree with in many ways,
个人的答案更准确。现在对此有两种观点。这两种观点是：我的观点是，随着我们消除噪音，我们会看到越来越高的相关性水平。换句话说，随着测试的改进、研究的开展更加仔细，玛扎琳表示，她预计相关性在个人层面上也会变得更好，而不仅仅是在国家层面。但她也提到了第二种可能性，即IAT实际上捕捉到了人们脑海中对更广泛文化中某些事物的反映。我非常钦佩并且在许多方面都赞同的人，
and I'm not opposed to this, but this is Keith Payne. He argues that these things don't operate at the level of the individual. You will never, no matter how much error variance you remove, it will never get better at the individual level because we become of a certain place when we go into a certain area. So he did this remarkable study because we become of a certain place when we go into a certain area.
我并不反对这一点，这就是基思·佩恩。他认为这些事情并不是在个人层面上运作的。无论你消除多少误差方差，它在个人层面上永远不会变得更好，因为当我们进入某个特定区域时，我们就会带上那个地方的烙印。所以他做了这项非凡的研究，因为当我们进入某个特定区域时，我们就会成为那个地方的一部分。
So he did this remarkable study that if I can just describe really quickly, I will tell you about it. Keith obtained a map that had been produced by Abraham Lincoln in the 1860s, in which Lincoln had his people plot county by county the proportion of enslaved to free people in every county in the southern states. And he did this because obviously he was this smart guy, a scientist almost, because he thought if I know that, if I know the proportion of enslaved people in a county, I will be able to make better military predictions about which counties are going to fall faster than other counties.
所以他做了这个非凡的研究，如果我能非常简短地描述一下，我会告诉你。基思获得了一张由亚伯拉罕·林肯在 1960 年代制作的地图，林肯让他的手下逐县绘制了南部各州每个县中奴隶人口与自由人口的比例。他这样做是因为很显然他是这个聪明人，几乎像个科学家，因为他认为如果我知道这一点，如果我知道一个县中奴隶人口的比例，我就能对哪些县会比其他县更快沦陷做出更好的军事预测。
And the simple idea was, the greater the proportion of enslaved people, the harder they will fight and the more they will resist giving up slavery. So this map exists even to this day. You can look at the map, you can see the counties and little numbers that tell us what the proportions are. So Keith, you know, in the 21st century goes back to this map and he says, let's correlate these two things. IAT raised bias in that county today and the number of enslaved to free people, proportions or ratios in 1860. And lo and behold, the correlation is quite substantial and high. And he will say exactly as we've been discussing he will say,
这个简单的想法是，奴隶人口的比例越高，他们就会进行越激烈的战斗，也越会抵制放弃奴隶制。所以这张地图至今仍然存在。你可以看这张地图，你可以看到这些县和告诉我们比例的小数字。所以基思，你知道的，在 21 世纪回到这张地图，他说，让我们把这两件事关联起来。今天该县的 IAT 种族偏见与 1860 年奴隶与自由人口的比例或比率。果不其然，相关性相当显著且很高。他会完全像我们一直在讨论的那样说，
well how can it be these are not the same people. Notice how surprising this is. Keith Bain, a psychologist at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill, looked at implicit bias test results for people in the 21st century. Why would these results be connected to policies that existed more than 150 years ago? Everyone who lived in those counties in the 1860s is now very dead. The proportions of enslaved to free people are not the people whose minds were measuring. In fact, we can't. They're gone.
怎么会这样呢？这些人并不是同一群人。注意这是多么令人惊讶。北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的心理学家基思·佩恩研究了21世纪人们的隐性偏见测试结果。为什么这些结果会与150多年前存在的政策联系起来？在1860年代生活在这些县里的每个人现在都早已去世了。奴隶与自由人口的比例并不是我们正在测量其大脑的人。事实上，我们不能。他们已经不在了。
And it's not even the case that the descendants of those very people live there today. In the United States, enough migrations have happened that that is not the case. So Keats' point of view, which is very interesting, is that your mind reflects what is right around you. And that if you were somebody who lived in Seattle and Microsoft Corporation sent you to some place in Georgia and you arrive there, you become of that place.
甚至也不是这些人的后代今天就住在那里。在美国，已经发生了足够多的移民，事实并非如此。因此，基思的观点非常有趣，那就是你的大脑反映了你周围的事情。如果你是一个住在西雅图的人，微软公司把你派到佐治亚州的某个地方，你到达那里，你就会变成那个地方的人。
If there are many Confederate statues in the town in which you live, your mind will move in the direction of more anti-black bias. Your children will hear certain things in school and they'll bring them to your home and as you talk about them, you too will start to acquire that. And these are the things that ultimately create these remarkable correlations almost unbelievable, and what it tells us is just the long shadow of history and how psychology is able to pick up this incredibly long shadow of history, that we can look at data from 1860 and we can predict today what that county's race bias is. Or we can look at the race
如果你居住的城镇里有很多邦联雕像，你的大脑就会朝着更多反黑人偏见的方向发展。你的孩子会在学校听到某些事情，他们会把这些事情带回家，当你们谈论这些事情时，你也会开始吸收这些。而这些最终创造了这些惊人的相关性（几乎令人难以置信），它告诉我们的是历史的漫长阴影，以及心理学如何能够捕捉到这极其漫长的历史阴影，我们可以查看 1860 年的数据，并预测今天该县的种族偏见。或者我们可以看看今天的种族
bias today and we can predict who those people were. I find this absolutely fascinating. In some ways, I think I'm hearing three different models. One says bias is produced by active animosity and hostility. People who act in biased ways mean to be biased. The second says, no, our minds are mirrors and when we go to different places, we are going to reflect what is out there. But I think there's also a third model, and I might call this the hypertension model. So if you would have measured my blood pressure right now and measured my blood pressure two hours from now or two days from now, it's
偏见，我们可以预测那些人是谁。我觉得这绝对令人着迷。在某些方面，我想我听到了三种不同的模型。一种说偏见是由积极的敌意和敌对产生的。以有偏见的方式行事的人是有意要表现出偏见的。第二种说，不，我们的心灵是镜子，当我们去不同的地方时，我们将反映出存在的东西。但我认为还有第三种模型，我可以称之为高血压模型。因此，如果你现在测量我的血压，并在两小时后或两天后测量我的血压，它会
going to fluctuate because blood pressure is not super stable. It depends on what's going on, what's happening to me physically, my mental state. But if you find that I do have high blood pressure, it doesn't necessarily tell you I'm going to have a heart attack next week, or I'm going to have a stroke next month. So in other words, it's a useful measure, but at an individual level, it's a somewhat crude measure of determining short term risk. But if you would step back and say,
波动，因为血压并不是超级稳定的。这取决于正在发生什么、我身体上发生了什么、我的精神状态。但是如果你发现我确实有高血压，它并不一定告诉你我下周会心脏病发作，或者下个月会中风。换句话说，这是一个有用的指标，但在个人层面上，它是确定短期风险的一个有点粗糙的指标。但如果你退后一步说，
what's the average hypertension of all the people in California or what's the average hypertension of all the people living in New York. And let's say the average hypertension in California was significantly higher than the average hypertension in New York. You could very confidently say you will have many more heart attacks and strokes in California than in New York, even though you can't predict which individuals are going to be affected. You can say something meaningful about the group, even if you can't be very precise about individuals. I mean, the same thing goes for smokers and non-smokers. I might not be able to tell you which individuals
加利福尼亚州所有人的平均高血压是多少，或者居住在纽约的所有人的平均高血压是多少。假设加利福尼亚州的平均高血压明显高于纽约州的平均高血压。你可以非常自信地说，加利福尼亚州的心脏病发作和中风会比纽约州多得多，尽管你无法预测哪些个人会受到影响。你可以对群体说些有意义的话，即使你无法对个人非常精确。我的意思是，吸烟者和非吸烟者也是如此。我可能无法告诉你哪些人
are going to develop cancer in any given week, but I know the group of smokers is going to have more cancers than the group of non-smokers. So both the mirror model and the hypertension model suggest that if you want to understand how unconscious biases caused by its actions, you need to look beyond the individual mind and look at larger systems and structures. I think you very much have it right.
会在任何给定的星期内患上癌症，但我知道吸烟者群体的患癌率会高于非吸烟者群体。因此，镜子模型和高血压模型都表明，如果你想了解无意识偏见是如何导致有偏见的行为的，你需要将目光投向个体心灵之外，去审视更大的系统和结构。我认为你的理解非常正确。
And I like the example of hypertension for many reasons, one of which is that the way we measure hypertension shows that the machine is not terribly reliable. For all the reasons that you said, if my arm is up or down, if I've just eaten, if I've walked, it will vary in sometimes substantially. There is error variance in that measure. The measure is not as good as it could be, same with the IAT. The IAT is not as perfect a measure as we would think or like it to be. So there's error variance there. However, your blood pressure does fluctuate. My brain is not the same brain as it was two hours ago. You know, having talked to you, a bunch of connections have now been made and my bias on some topic because we've been
我喜欢高血压的例子有很多原因，其中之一就是我们测量高血压的方式表明机器并不是非常可靠。出于你所说的所有原因，如果我的手臂向上或向下，如果我刚吃过饭，如果我走过路，它会有所变化，有时甚至是大幅度变化。该测量中存在误差方差。测量结果不如其应有的那么好，IAT也是如此。IAT并不像我们想象或希望的那样是一个完美的测量工具。所以那里存在误差方差。然而，你的血压确实会波动。我的大脑已经不是两个小时前的大脑了。你知道，和你交谈后，现在已经建立了很多连接，由于我们在讨论这个话题，我对某个主题的偏见可能会比以前更高或更低。换句话说，IAT 实际上是在捕捉你现在的大脑的真实状态，这与昨天不同，因此真实的、我们所说的可靠性很低。所以我想当我们把所有这些放在一起时，这就是像你的高血压例子一样的一根电线。我喜欢高血压例子的另一个原因时，当我教书时，当我说，“你知道，高血压被称为沉默的杀手，因为你感觉不到它。”
talking about it could be higher or lower than it was. In other words, the IAT is actually picking up the real state of your brain now, which was different than it was yesterday, and therefore the real, what we will say is the reliability is low. So I think when we put it all together, so this is one strand of wire like your hypertension example. The other reason I like the hypertension example is when I teach, when I say, you know, hypertension is called the silent killer because you don't feel it.
你知道，它不像骨关节炎那样，疼痛会告诉你你的身体发生了什么。但难道我们不想知道我们是否患有此病吗？难道我们不想发明那些虽然不太可靠但仍然可以挽救我们生命的装置吗？我想这种尝试——我这里不是在谈论 IAT，我是在谈论任何试图弄清这种隐性认知的尝试——我认为这与我们为身体做的事情完全一样，我们在为我们的心灵做同样的事情。我们正在试图发明一种可能不是很可靠的测量方法，但可以给我们提供足够的证据
You know, it's not like osteoarthritis or something where the pain tells you that something is going on in your body. But wouldn't we want to know that we have it? And don't we want to invent gizmos that are not very reliable but can still save our lives? I think of this attempt, and I'm not speaking about the IAT here, I'm speaking about any attempt to try to get at this kind of implicit cognition, I think it's exactly the same thing that we're trying to do for our mind as we do for our body. We're trying to invent a measure that may not be very reliable, but could give us enough evidence
以至于我们会说，你知道的，知道了这一点，我会改变我的行为。我会以不同的方式做事。所以我非常喜欢高血压的例子。你知道，它确实提出了一个问题，那就是，在这些措施实际上在总体层面比在个人层面告诉我们更多有用信息的程度上（无论是基思·佩恩的观点，即我们的心灵确实反映了我们周围正在发生的事情——换句话说，你在对我的个人测量中捕捉到的实际上是我对周围社会和文化中事物的反映；或者，在高血压例子的情境下，在预测心脏病发作和中风将发生在哪里方面，当把我的高血压与周围所有其他人的高血压聚合在一起时，我的高血压实际上更具有线索关联性），在所有这些情况下，这难道不会引发对解决这些偏见的流行模型的质疑吗？消除隐性偏见的很多努力都是关于试图从个人大脑中根除偏见。当你想到各个公司和企业的多元化、公平和包容（DEI）努力时，其中很大一部分
that we would say, you know what, knowing this, I will change my behavior. I will do things in a different way. And so I just love the hypertension example. You know, one question it does raise, though, is that to the extent that these measures are in fact telling us something more useful at the aggregate level than at the individual level, you know, whether that's the key pain idea that our minds are really reflecting what's happening around us. In other words, what you're picking up in the measure of me as an individual is really
就是我们会给你一个测试，我们会通过测试向你展示你有偏见，然后我们将试图通过训练消除你身上的这种偏见。如果事实上偏见来自社会，如果事实上它是社会的反映，或者如果事实上它是我们所属的更大系统和结构的一部分，那么试图说我们实际上可以只修复个人头脑并希望解决问题，是不是一场徒劳的追求？从某种意义上说，我不能更赞同你的观点了。我会说，认为我们可以进入一家公司（尤其是像目前这样），做一次关于隐性这个或那个的演讲，然后假设我们已经勾选了复选框，现在我们没有隐性偏见，这种想法是一场徒劳的追求。正如弗兰克·多宾（Frank Dobbin）等人所说，
my reflection of what's in the society and the culture around me. Or, in the case of the hypertension example, my hypertension is actually more relevant as a clue when you aggregate it with the hypertension of all the other people around me in terms of predicting where the heart attacks and strokes are going to be. In both those cases, does it not raise questions about the model of fixing these biases that seems to have become very popular, where so much of the efforts to fix implicit bias has been about trying to eradicate bias from individual brains. When you think about DEI efforts at various companies and corporations, so much of that
这反映了我周围的社会和文化。或者，以高血压为例，当我把我的高血压与周围所有其他人的高血压结合起来预测心脏病和中风将要发生的位置时，我的高血压实际上作为一条线索更具相关性。在这两种情况下，这难道不会让人对目前似乎变得非常流行的纠正这些偏见的模式产生疑问吗？在纠正内隐偏见的众多努力中，很大一部分都是关于试图从个人大脑中根除偏见。当你想到各个公司和企业的多元、公平和包容（DEI）努力时，其中很大一部分
is we'll give you a test, we'll show you through the test that you have bias, and then we're going to try and train this bias out of you. If in fact the bias comes from the society, if in fact it's a reflection of the society, or in fact it's part of the larger systems and structures in which we're part of, is it a fool's errand to try and say we can actually just fix individual minds and hope to solve the problem? In one sense I couldn't agree with you more. I would say that it is a fool's errand to think that we can go into a corporation, especially as it is currently done, come and give a talk on implicit this or that, and then assume that we've checked off our box and now we don't have implicit bias. In Go Frank Dobin and others and say,
就是我们会给你做一个测试，通过测试向你展示你存在偏见，然后我们试图通过培训将这种偏见从你身上消除。如果事实上偏见来自社会，如果事实上它是社会的反映，或者事实上它是我们所属的更大系统和结构的一部分，那么试图说我们实际上只需修复个人思维并期望解决这个问题，是不是一件吃力不讨好的傻事？从某种意义上说，我不能赞同你更多。我会说，认为我们可以进入一家公司——尤其是像目前这样——来做一个关于内隐这个或那个的讲座，然后就假设我们已经打勾完成了任务，现在我们没有内隐偏见了，这种想法就是一种傻事。正如弗兰克·多宾（Frank Dobbin）等人所说，
the people who did the NIH training, nothing happened there. Maasuring is referring here to work by the sociologist Frank Dobin and Alexandra Kallev, who find that mandatory diversity training, as practiced by many corporations today, is not only ineffective, but frequently counterproductive. So, that's not a surprise, because the intervention is not up to the task of actually changing anything real. I do believe, though, that that education is necessary. And it's necessary not because it will change an individual person's bias,
参加美国国立卫生研究院培训的人，那里什么都没有发生。马扎林在这里指的是社会学家弗兰克·多宾（Frank Dobin）和亚历山德拉·卡列夫（Alexandra Kalev）的研究。他们发现，正如许多企业今天所实施的那样，强制性的多元化培训不仅无效，而且往往适得其反。所以，这并不令人意外，因为这种干预根本无法真正改变任何现实。不过，我确实认为这种教育是必要的。它的必要性不在于改变某个个人的偏见，
but it will make them open to structural changes their organization will want to make. So if I work with any group that comes to me and says, what shall we do? I will say, I will teach them about implicit bias in a scientific way. You can't do this if it's mandatory. I will only come if it's voluntary. And what I think we will achieve is that when you then go to them and you say, you know what, the way we run interviews is really bad. Interviews are a terrible way to make decisions. We are going to terrible way to make decisions. We are going to start to do something differently. We are going to get resumes with much harder good evidence.
而是能让他们更容易接受组织想要做出的结构性改革。因此，如果我与任何找到我的群体合作并被问到“我们该怎么做？”时，我会说，我将以科学的方式向他们传授隐性偏见。如果是强制性的，那就无法做到这一点。只有在自愿的前提下我才会参与。我认为我们将实现的目标是，当你随后找到他们并对他们说：“你知道吗，我们进行面试的方式真的很糟糕。面试是做出决策的糟糕方式。我们要换一种方式做事了。我们将收到证据更为确凿的简历。
We are not going to let people write their hobbies on their resumes. We are going to do these screenings. We are going to bring interns in for six months and we are going to pick from that instead of these silly ways in which we did. I believe that if that education has been done well, that you will be able to make all these institutional level changes that will ultimately change the level of bias because you will have fixed it by intervening in the right moments. So I'm very clear with organizations. If you want to change people, I'm not the right person for you,
我们不会让人在简历上写下他们的爱好。我们将进行这些筛选。我们将让实习生进来工作六个月，然后从他们当中挑选，而不是用我们以前那些愚蠢的方法。”我相信，如果这种教育做得很好，你将能够进行所有这些机构层面的变革，这最终将改变偏见的程度，因为你通过在正确的时刻进行干预解决了这个问题。因此，我对各个组织说得很清楚：如果你想改变人们，我不是适合你的人选，
I will, in fact, agree very much with you, Shankar, in saying that that would be a fool, Zaryn. But I don't say don't educate them because I do believe that the education plays the role of making individuals feel secure as to why we're going about changing our organization. If police officers in Cambridge who I've worked with haven't been in a session with me and haven't learned why what I'm saying is in their interest they will resist every little step of the way wearing a body camera wearing a bulletproof vest and every. But after a session like this and we have a paper in which we're going to summarize, the massive shift in attitudes that we've seen in police officers prior to an educational
事实上，尚卡尔，我非常同意你的看法，认为那样做会是个傻瓜，赞林。但我并不是说不要教育他们，因为我确实相信，教育发挥着这样的作用：让个人感到安心，明白我们为什么要着手改变我们的组织。如果我曾与之合作过的剑桥警察没有参加过我的课程，没有了解到我所说的话为什么符合他们的利益，他们就会在佩戴随身摄像头、穿防弹衣等每一个微小的步骤上进行抵制。但在这样的一场课程之后——我们有一篇论文将总结我们在警察参加教育研讨会之前和之后所看到的态度上的巨大转变。
seminar and post an educational seminar. Now they're saying, yeah, I see why this is good for me. So I believe in teaching and I believe it's necessary, but nowhere sufficient. in teaching and I believe it's necessary, but nowhere sufficient. When we come back, how change happens? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Maserine Banaji had a formative experience growing up in India. She was a member of a minority group that was all but invisible. So the short version is that Zorastrianism is known today as the oldest monotheistic religion in the world. Its origins were in Central Asia, in particular in what was then the Persian Empire. And Zorastrianism was the state-religion.
现在他们会说：“是的，我明白为什么这对我有好处了。”所以我相信教学，我也认为这是必要的，但远远不够。当我们回来时，变革是如何发生的？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家马扎林·巴纳吉（Mazarin Banaji）在印度度过了一段对她产生深远影响的成长经历。她是一个几乎隐形的少数群体成员。简而言之，琐罗亚斯德教（Zoroastrianism）如今被认为是世界上最古老的一神教。它的起源在中亚，特别是在当时的波斯帝国。琐罗亚斯德教曾是国教。
It was a very successful religion. It spread far and wide until about the 8th century, when Islamic invasions of that part of the world began, and over two centuries, somewhere between the 8th and 10th century, Zorastrians who did not wish to be converted, took off in little boats looking for asylum, religious asylum. And I guess the first country that allowed them that religious asylum was India.
这是一个非常成功的宗教。它传播得又远又广，直到大约8世纪，该地区开始遭到伊斯兰军队的入侵。在随后的两个世纪里，即8世纪到10世纪之间的某个时期，不愿改宗的琐罗亚斯德教徒乘坐小船出发，寻找庇护，即宗教庇护。我想，第一个允许他们获得这种宗教庇护的国家是印度。
It was on the west coast of India that they landed in Gujarat. And the story goes that the local king met them and said to them, we are full. There are many of us here,, we can't take you in. And at least the apocryphal story is that the captain of this little boat asked for some milk and sugar because they couldn't speak the same language. And use this, put the sugar into the milk, stirred it and explained that we would just blend in and that we would
他们在印度的西海岸古吉拉特邦登陆。故事说，当地的国王接见了他们，并对他们说：“我们这里已经满了。这里有很多人，我们容纳不下你们。”至少这个民间传说是这样的：这艘小船的船长因为语言不通，要了一些牛奶和糖。他把糖放进牛奶里，搅拌了一下，并解释说，他们会融入这里，
sweeten the milk. And the king was so happy with this demo that he apparently letters in and said, you can practice your religion, you can have whatever beliefs you wish, you have to speak our language and where are dress. Growing up, Mazarin often felt pulled in two directions. Ever the observer, she noticed when this happened and what it meant. I'll just give you one example. In my own community of Zorastrians, but particularly in my family, I was considered dark-skinned.
并且会让牛奶变甜。国王对这个演示非常满意，显然让他们留了下来，并说：“你们可以信奉你们的宗教，你们可以拥有你们希望的任何信仰，你们必须说我们的语言并穿我们的衣服。”在成长过程中，马扎林经常觉得自己被拉向两个方向。作为一名敏锐的观察者，每当这种情况发生时，她都会注意到，并且明白这意味着什么。我只举一个例子。在我自己的琐罗亚斯德教社群里，特别是我的家庭中，我被认为是皮肤黑的人。
I was. People would say things to me like, oh, you know, Karice. Karice means she's black. But when I would step out of the house, I would be considered pale-skinned in South India. So what was I, very early? It was a conundrum.
我的确是。人们会对我说这样的话：“哦，你知道的，卡里斯（Karice）。”卡里斯的意思是她很黑。但当我走出家门时，在南印度我却被认为皮肤白皙。所以，我很小的时候究竟算什么？这是一个谜题。
Am I dark skinned or am I light skinned? I think it taught me that there was clearly nothing inherent in the physical aspect of my skin color that made me light or dark. it's the context that made it so. In India, the Zoroastrian community is known as the Parse community. Likely because the first Zoroastrians were associated with travelers from Pars, a region of Iran. Maserine said she always sensed the Parse community had to stand apart from the larger Indian society.
我是皮肤黑还是皮肤白？我认为这教会了我，我的肤色在物理层面上显然没有任何本质属性让我变得白或者黑。是语境让它变成了这样。在印度，琐罗亚斯德教社群被称为帕西社群（Parse）。这很可能是因为最早的琐罗亚斯德教徒与来自伊朗帕尔斯（Pars）地区的旅行者有关。马扎林说，她一直感觉到帕西社群必须与更广泛的印度社会保持距离。
It was communicated in a very sort of sideways way. Nobody said to us, you cannot do X. But we just knew we couldn't. If you needed something fixed, you would call the Parseic neighbor who would call, you know, the Parseic neighbor who would call the Parcy friend who would come and fix it. You didn't participate in society. And I only learned this when I married somebody from the dominant group. And I watched how his family operated.
这种信息是以一种非常迂回的方式传达的。没有人对我们说“你不能做X”。但我们就是知道我们不能。如果你需要修理什么东西，你会打电话给帕西邻居，然后他会打电话给……你知道的，帕西邻居会打电话给帕西朋友，然后那个人会来修理。你不参与社会活动。而我直到嫁给了一个来自主流群体的人时才明白这一点。我看着他的家人是如何生活的。
And I thought, wow, that's what it means to have access. It just normal stuff. My father wouldn't even collect the reimbursements of health insurance that would have come to him because he was a government servant. He just wouldn't participate in those sorts of things. We wouldn't feel we had access, but we knew that we would be safe. Nobody was going to come kill us or anything. But we had to just stay outside the mainstream in some way.
然后我想：“哇，这才是拥有特权阶层的含义。”这只是正常的事情。我父亲甚至不会去领取本应属于他的医疗保险报销，尽管他是政府雇员。他就是不肯参与那种事情。我们不觉得自己拥有特权，但我们知道我们会是安全的。没有人会来杀我们什么的。但我们必须在某种程度上游离于主流之外。
Maserine told me that while she was deeply enmeshed in Parse culture while living in India, it was only when she came to the United States that she really started to understand her family's faith. I learned a lot about my own religion when I came to Yale as an assistant professor, and I met Stanley Insler, who was a scholar of Zorastronism, and particularly of the Holy Book, which I can, you know, I can rattle off many thousands of lines of code in a language called Avastan, but I
马扎林告诉我，虽然她在印度生活时深深沉浸在帕西文化中，但直到她来到美国，她才真正开始理解她家族的信仰。当我作为助理教授来到耶鲁大学时，我对自己宗教有了很多了解。我遇到了斯坦利·因斯勒（Stanley Insler），他是研究琐罗亚斯德教的学者，特别是其圣书的学者。我能脱口说出用阿维斯塔语（Avastan）编写的数千行代码般的经文，但我
don't understand it. And what I learned by reading Stanley's books is that Zorastronism takes as its core principle the recognition that the world is constructed of good and evil, and that the job of every Zorastron every day is to ask on which side am I going to be. And that when you review your life, that's what you look at. How many times was I on the side of good or not? And I think of that as both quite profound, but also somewhat ironic. I only noticed it years after we had worked on implicit attitudes that the fundamental dimension I study is the dimension of good and bad.
却并不理解它。通过阅读斯坦利的著作，我了解到琐罗亚斯德教的核心原则是认识到世界是由善与恶构成的，而每个琐罗亚斯德教徒每天的工作就是问自己将站在哪一边。当你回顾自己的一生时，这就是你所审视的。我站在善这一边有多少次，或者没有？我认为这既深刻又有点讽刺。直到我们研究隐性态度多年之后，我才注意到我所研究的基本维度正是“好与坏”的维度。
Some time ago, one of Maizarin students came to her with a research idea that had direct bearing on this question of good and bad. Was it possible Tessa Charles were asked that implicit biases were actually receding, that the United States was becoming less biased? I was completely confident, and I even said to her, yeah, you're not going to see any change, not in our lifetime. I mean, change will happen, but if you look at the IAT from 2007 to today, my prediction, no change, it'll be a flat line over time because implicit bias changes, but not fast.
不久前，马扎林的一名学生带着一个研究想法来找她，该想法与这个“好与坏”的问题直接相关。泰莎·查尔斯沃思（Tessa Charlesworth）提出，隐性偏见是否实际上在消退，美国是否正在变得不再那么偏见？我完全充满信心，甚至对她说：“是的，你不会看到任何改变，在我们有生之年都不会。我是说，改变会发生，但如果你看看2007年至今的IAT（内隐联想测验），我的预测是：没有改变，随着时间的推移，它将是一条平坦的直线，因为隐性偏见会改变，但不会很快。”
So Tessa does these lovely analysis. And what the data show is something quite stunning. On the sexuality test, the anti-gay bias test, bias was quite high. Anti-gay bias was quite high in 2007. But with every day, every month, since then, it has slowly been coming down. So that in 2020, that bias has come down close to neutrality.
于是，泰莎做了这些漂亮的分析。数据显示了一些非常惊人的结果。在性取向测试、反同性恋偏见测试中，偏见相当高。2007年，反同性恋偏见相当高。但从那时起的每一天、每个月，它都在缓慢下降。以至于到了2020年，这种偏见已经下降到接近中立。
What Maserina Tessa found was that between 2007 and 2020, anti-K bias decreased by nearly two thirds. It's not yet neutral, but we're predicting our model predicts that in one and a half years, Americans will be at neutrality on that. There are also encouraging signs when it comes to biases based on race. Race bias has also come down on two kinds of measures, the black white test, and also the dark skin, light skin test, which is not race, but could be seen as another proxy for something akin to race.
马扎林和泰莎发现，在2007年至2020年间，反同性恋偏见下降了近三分之二。它虽然尚未达到中立，但我们的预测模型预测，在一年半的时间里，美国人在这一问题上将达到中立。在基于种族的偏见方面，也有令人鼓舞的迹象。种族偏见也在两类测量中有所下降：黑白测试，以及深肤色与浅肤色测试——后者虽然不是种族，但可以被视为类似于种族的某种替代指标。
Both tests show exactly the same drop in bias by 25%. So it is not nothing, but it is not 64%. Which we know it could be if we were doing things the way we're doing for sexuality bias. To recap, Mazurine and Tessa's data found that race bias has come down by 25% and anti-gay bias by a remarkable 64%. That's the good news.
这两项测试显示出完全相同的偏见下降幅度：25%。所以这并非毫无进展，但它不是64%。我们知道，如果我们像对待性取向偏见那样做事，它本可以达到这个数字。概括一下，马扎林和泰莎的数据发现，种族偏见下降了25%，而反同性恋偏见则显著下降了64%。这是好消息。
The bad news? There are three other types of bias where the data haven't budged at all. Anti-eldrally bias, disability bias, body weight bias. These stigmas, I think, are going to be much harder to change. They're visible, they're on the body, and we don't talk about them nearly enough. We're not arguing about age, bias, or disability or body weight. In fact, body weight bias, people express quite explicitly. That may be a part of it, but also these are going to be harder to change. Right now if we do nothing, those biases are with us for at least 200 years. That's what our model predicts. Let me go back to sexuality and just say one thing about it that I think is incredibly interesting. We thought, okay, it's changing, but it must be young people only or
坏消息呢？还有另外三种类型的偏见，其数据根本没有丝毫动静：对老年人的偏见、残疾偏见、体重偏见。我认为，这些污名要难改变得多。它们是可见的，存在于身体上，而且我们对它们的讨论远远不够。我们没有在争论年龄偏见、残疾或体重。事实上，人们非常明确地表达对体重的偏见。这可能是其中的一部分，但这些偏见也更难改变。目前如果我们什么都不做，这些偏见将伴随我们至少200年。这就是我们的模型所预测的。让我回到性取向，并就此说一件我认为极其有趣的事情。我们曾想：好吧，它在改变，但它一定只发生在年轻人身上，或者是
a certain part, a certain demographic group. Gay people only, things like that. And it turns out, no, everybody is changing. Conservatives are changing, and liberals are changing. Elderly are changing, and young are changing. Educated and less educated are changing. Rich are changing, and poor are changing and young are changing, educated and less educated are changing. Rich are changing and poor are changing. So I think these results are together really exciting to us. It tells us that change is possible at this societal level. As we put this episode together, Republicans and Democrats in the Senate
某个特定部分、特定的统计群体。比如只有同性恋者之类的。结果证明，并非如此，所有人在改变。保守派在改变，自由派在改变。老年人在改变，年轻人也在改变。受过教育和受教育较少的人在改变。富人在改变，穷人在改变，年轻人也在改变，受过教育和受教育较少的人在改变，富人和穷人都在改变。因此，我认为这些结果对我们来说非常令人兴奋。它告诉我们，这种社会层面的变革是可能的。在我们制作这集节目的时候，参议院的共和党人和民主党人
came together to pass landmark legislation and shining the right to gay marriage. I find it difficult to imagine this would have happened if it were not for a sea change in public attitudes, a sea change that the implicit bias test seems to have picked up. Mazarin points to the forces driving the change, there was change at the individual level as grandparents reconciled themselves with their grandchildren's sexuality, changes at an institutional level as companies began offering same-sex
携手通过了一项具有里程碑意义的立法，将同性婚姻的权利法律化。我很难想象，如果没有公众态度的巨变——这种巨变似乎已被隐性偏见测试捕捉到——这一切会发生。马扎林指出了推动这一变革的力量：在个人层面，祖父母们接受了孙辈的性取向，发生了改变；在机构层面，公司开始向员工提供同性伴侣
benefits to workers, and change at the level of national policy in terms of laws and Supreme Court decisions. All three happened within a tight period of time, and when you have changed at this many different levels of society from the individual human to the Supreme Court, that's when you can get a 64% drop in implicit bias, anti-gay bias. To be clear, the fact that there has been a dramatic drop in anti-gay bias does not mean the pendulum cannot swing back.
福利，发生了改变；在国家政策层面，法律和最高法院的裁决也发生了改变。这三个层面都在紧凑的时间段内发生了变化，而当你在社会的如此多个不同层面——从个人到最高法院——都发生了改变时，你才能使隐性偏见、反同性恋偏见下降64%。需要明确的是，反同性恋偏见大幅下降这一事实，并不意味着历史的车轮不会倒退。
There are jurisdictions across the US and around the world that are actively trying to curtail LGBTQ rights. There is a two-way street between what happens in our minds and public policy. Laws can change because of the biases in our heads, but our biases can also change as a result of laws and cultural shifts. I know that you don't think of yourself as being a religious person,
美国各地和世界各地都有一些司法管辖区正在积极试图削减LGBTQ+的权利。我们内心的想法与公共政策之间存在着双向作用。法律可能会因为我们脑海中的偏见而改变，但我们的偏见也可能因为法律和文化转变而改变。我知道你并不认为自己是一个有宗教信仰的人，
but again, I'm struck by something you told me about what it means to be a good par-sea. You know, the good par-sea recognizes that the world has good and evil and has to try and make a choice every day with side they're on. Do you feel like you do that in your own life? I mean, consciously, yes. Almost, almost like writing in a book. One of the things I teach about is that our ancestors had very clear evidence every day about the harm
但同样地，你曾告诉我关于做一个好的帕西人意味着什么，这让我深有触动。你知道，好的帕西人认识到世界有善有恶，并且必须努力每天做出选择，决定自己站在哪一边。你觉得你在自己的生活中也这样做了吗？我是说，有意识地，是的。几乎，几乎就像在账本上记账一样。我所教授的内容之一是，我们的祖先每天都有非常明确的证据，证明他们对那些与他们不同的人造成了伤害。他们会骑上马，闯入某个邻近的村庄进行掠夺，把别人的东西搬回自己的村庄。因此，在一天结束时，如果你问我们苔原上的祖先：你伤害了与你不同的人吗？他们会回答：“妈的，我当然伤害了。”他们有直接的证据。你我生活在一个受到如此保护和特权的世界上，以至于我们每天不必做那样的事情。我们没有伤害与我们不同的人的体验。那么，我们是如何进行歧视的呢？我们确实在歧视。我们以一种非常矛盾的方式这样做。
that they did to people who were not like them. They would get on a horse, they would go into some neighboring village and loot it and bring their stuff back to theirs. So at the end of the day, if you asked, our ancestors on the Tundra, did you harm somebody who was not like you? They would say, damn right, I did. They would have direct evidence. You and I live in such a protected and privileged world that we don't have to do that every day. We don't have the experience of harming people who are different from us. So how is it that we discriminate and we do? We do it in a very paradoxical way.
我们通过我们帮助谁来进行歧视。我认为，这就是“我是否是一个好人”不再是一个简单问题的地方。因为如果我帮助我自己的族群——我确信我确实这样做过——我不应该把这算在“好”的那一栏里，除非我在另一栏里做了一种补偿性的行为，而这非常难以做到。这就是为什么机构和政府必须介入的原因。这是因为你和我作为个人都会提供帮助。如果我的朋友打电话给我说：
We do it by who we help. And I think that this is where have I been a good person is no longer a simple question. Because if I help people from my own tribe, which I sure I do, I should not count that in the good column, until I've done a compensating behavior in the other column, which is very hard to do. And which is why institutions and governments have to enter? It is because you and I, as individuals, will help. If my friend calls me up and says,
“我儿子最近状态不好，他能来你的实验室过个夏天吗？”我会说好。而且我不想成为那种不做这种事的人。但如果这种情况正在发生，那么我的机构就需要有一个项目，让那些不是我朋友孩子的其他人也能来参观我的实验室。这就是为什么我认为“帮助”往往会成为我们维系世界不平等的一种方式，然而我们却不把它当作我们做过的、不应引以为傲的事情来看待。所以你看它是多么复杂，然而每天当我从事这种工作并看到源源不断的数据时，
my son is not doing well, can he come and spend a summer in your lab, I will say yes. And I don't think I want to be the kind of person who doesn't do that. But if that's happening, then my institution needs to have a program by which people who are not the children of my friend can visit my lab. And this is why I think helping can often be the way in which we keep the world unequal and yet we don't count it as something that we've done that is not something we should be proud of. So you see how it's complicated and yet every day, when I do the kind of work and see the data that come in,
我在琐罗亚斯德教的账本中被转化为我认为应该归入好与坏栏目的内容。马扎林·巴纳吉是哈佛大学的心理学家。她与托尼·格林wald（Tony Greenwald）合著了《盲点：好人背后的隐性偏见》（Blind Spot: Hidden Biases of Good People）。马扎林，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。非常荣幸。几周前，我们做了一个实验，我们想再次尝试。我们正在探索进行例行后续对话的可能性，我们的听众可以在其中向我们的嘉宾提出他们的问题。如果你有任何问题或想法
I am being transformed in what I think is to go into the good and bad column of the Zorastrian ledger. Maasareen Panaji is a psychologist at Harvard University. Along with Tony Greenwald, she's the author of Blind Spot, Hidden Biasis of Good People. Maasareen, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brighton. Thank you for having me. Always a pleasure. Some weeks ago, we ran an experiment, and we would like to do it again. We're exploring the possibility of regular follow-up conversations in which our listeners can pose their questions to our guests. If you have questions or thoughts
关于我们与马扎林·巴纳吉的系列节目，并且愿意与更广泛的《隐藏的大脑》听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制一条语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。请记得附上你的姓名以及我们可以联系到你的电话号码。再次提醒，请将问题发送至：ideas@hiddenbrain.org，并在主题行中注明“隐性偏见节目”（implicit bias episodes）。《隐藏的大脑》由“隐藏的大脑”传媒公司（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保尔（Ani Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷莱（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。
about our series with Maserine Banagji and are willing to have those questions shared with a larger hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. Please remember to include your name and a phone number where we can reach you. Again, email the questions to us at ideasathydenbrain.org and use the subject line, implicit bias episodes. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick.
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。特别感谢本集的音效设计师尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。我们今天的无名英雄是听众兼《隐藏的大脑》支持者、来自加利福尼亚州奥克兰的布伦丹·史密斯（Brendan Smith）。布伦丹说他喜欢在带着他的金毛寻回犬麦克斯（Max）散步时收听《隐藏的大脑》。布伦丹，我们非常高兴能陪伴你和麦克斯散步。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks for this episode to Sound Designer Nick Woodbury. Our run sunk hero today is listener and Hidden Brain supporter, Brendan Smith of Oakland, California. Brendan says he likes to listen to Hidden Brain while walking with his golden retriever, Max. We're really glad to be part of your walks with Max, Brendan.
非常感谢你的支持。如果你觉得这一集引人深思，并且愿意和布伦丹一起帮助我们制作更多这样的节目，请尽你的一份力让我们继续蓬勃发展。帮助我们为新听众制作更多节目。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Thanks so much for your support. If you found this episode thought-provoking, and you would like to join Brendan in helping us to make more episodes like this, please do your part to keep us thriving. Help us build more shows for new listeners. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢您的支持。如果您觉得这一集引人深思，并且希望加入布伦丹的行列，帮助我们制作更多这样的节目，请尽自己的一份力让我们继续蓬勃发展。帮助我们为新听众制作更多节目。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。